[Music]
the Oscars are this coming Sunday and a
lot of people are excited about that and
there are 10 nominees for Best Picture
now if you haven't had a chance to see
all the movies
don't you worry cuz Andy and I this week
are helping people out all right here's
what we're doing we we did this we're
going to once again perform a pivotal
scene from one of the nominated films
that way this weekend yeah yes and it's
free yeah and this way when you go to a
Oscar party this weekend you'll kind of
know what you're talking about you'll be
up on all the movies so we've already
done this week
scenes from inception and the Black Swan
and those went those were oh dreadful
for tonight's film we've chosen to do a
scene from the generation-defining epic
the social network lights back up please
um throughout this film Mark Zuckerberg
has been accused of stealing the idea
for Facebook from the entitled
Winklevoss twins yeah right and the
twins have tried to reason with him but
he's avoided all contact with the
Winklevoss twins so they take their case
to the president of the university who
is former US Treasury Secretary Larry
Summers which I'll be playing that part
a you Larry Summers and with the help of
some cutting-edge special effects I will
be playing both Tyler and Cameron the
handsome and athletic Winklevoss twins
let's do that right now
[Laughter]
okay what's first of all let's get that
smirk there's a sort of Winklevoss smirk
is there let's get a freeze on that
[Applause]
[Music]
these is your twin you haven't done a
mind-meld
[Laughter]
yeah twins I forgot don't do this yeah
yeah this is something twins never do
sorry it's just fun I'm feeling this
could go on for yeah yeah cancel all the
guests now finally to help with the
scene we've asked our graphics designer
pierre bernard to play the role of
president summers secretary and he never
says no to anything
it's a lot of that room alright let's
let's begin okay I'm the president of
Harvard and I don't see this as a
university issue of course it's the
university issue there's a code of
ethics in an honor code and he violated
them both well you entered into it you
entered into a code of ethics with the
university not with each other
I'm sorry president summers what you
just said that both of us makes no sense
to me at all well I'm devastated by that
this idea is potentially worth millions
of dollars millions you might be letting
your imagination run away with you
letting our imaginations run away with
us is exactly what we were told to do
and you you're overdoing it a little bit
it's exactly that it's exactly what we
were told to do in your freshman address
well I would try letting your
imagination run away with you on a new
project now is there anything else I can
do for you oh yeah yeah there is
I wouldn't mind very much if you took a
flying stay out of this thank you for
your time sir
you are so fired stay out of this thank
you for your time sir we appreciate you
seeing us and show these gentlemen the
door please
they seem like a couple of dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]